philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien et membres d
econoclaste philippe béchade bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors promouvoir le yoann c'est
un peu la devise de la chine en si je
puis dire
est ce que c'est une manière d'éviter de
possibles sanctions économiques la part
des états unis ont cédé clairement
positive bien sûr que les états unis
usent et abusent de leur pouvoir voir si
si qui s'exerce au travers du dollar et
du dollar et du visage qui en est fait
alors en plus de ça la chine comme vous
venez de le mentionner risque de se voir
privés d'un accès privilégié aux marchés
occidentaux au travers de la plate forme
financière de hong kong
et ça ça sera évidemment un coup très
dur ça fait pas ce n'était pas dire bien
sûr un ace que la chaîne a la
possibilité est ce qu'elle a le poids
pour imposer sa monnaie face au dollar
sur les marchés ce que c'est une est-ce
que c'est faisable
je pense que c'est faisable
la chine est déjà le numéro un en termes
de production manufacturière dans le
monde au niveau des brevets la chine
n'est pas très loin de rejoindre les
états unis donc pour ce qui est des
activités tertiaires et scientifique
jean ping a fixé un cap à 2025 pour que
la chine soit numéro un
et puis je rappelle tout de même qu
historiquement la chine a été numéro 1
mondial peut-être de la chute de
l'empiré romain
jusqu'au 14 ou 15e siècle la route de la
soie faisait
9000 kilomètres jusqu'à l' empire
byzantin s'étendait sur verre l'euphrate
la route de la soie existait déjà
d'ailleurs du temps des romains et
pendant des siècles et des siècles la
sap ecc
c'était la monnaie chinoise est elle
amenée des changes
pratiquement sur tout le continent
asiatique autrement dit la chine a connu
pendant des siècles et des siècles un
crime monétaire que les états unis
exercent depuis on va dire environ 70
sous ou 80 ans donc la chine pourrait
retrouver tout simplement ou renouer
avec son histoire en redevenant un pays
dont la devise est une référence pour
tous les échanges commerciaux alors on a
vu il ya aussi une contestation de plus
en plus forte de l'hégémonie du dollar à
l'international de la part de la russie
de l'iran
est ce que cela pourrait jouer en faveur
du jeune bien sûr d'ailleurs avant de
revenir sur sur l'iran et d'autres pays
avec lequel la chine commerce il ya la
russie où les achats de pétrole se
règlent désormais non plus sur la base
d'une référence de l'armée sur la base
d'une référence or donc lâchent-ils à
l'iran depuis l'embargo américain et
même bien avant la chine était déjà de
très très loin le principal fournisseur
de l'iran le problème c'est que l'iran
aujourd'hui a du mal à exporter le
pétrole
autrement dit le système des changes qui
existait il est pour l'instant un peu
déséquilibré du fait des sanctions
américaines
ensuite eh bien tous les pays qui vont
adhérer
quelque part au projet de route sur la
soirée ça va aller jusqu'à l'amérique du
sud l'afrique c'est déjà bien connu
beaucoup de pays africains commercent
avec lâché non plus en dollars mais avec
des références matières premières et
c'est donc la chine veut évidemment
échappé au contrôle exercé sur les âges
du dollar par contre le risque pour tous
les pays qui vont être associés à la rue
de douai
de la soie c'est que la chine renoue
également avec son passé impose ses
propres conditions et son propre droit
commercial avec tous ses pays
partenaires
une dernière question philippe béchade
sur le long terme il ya cette ambition
de détrôner le dollar s quel serait
selon vous la position de l'union
européenne et face à tout cela
s comme lui on reprenne pourrait
approuver par exemple ce processus alors
il est clair qu'en lieu que dans l'union
européenne
l'hégémonie et l'extra territorialité du
droit américain
ça agace de longue date le pavot faire
la liste de toutes les entreprises
européennes qui ont été sanctionnés et
qui ont dû payer des amendes qui ça
s'appelle du racket aux américains
puisque ce sont des jugements
unilatéraux et en vertu du droit
américain
alors que du point de vue du droit
européen les entreprises condamnées
n'avait rien commis d'illégal
évidemment en europe on voudrait bien
aussi échappé au jcp hoa et la chine
plus spécifiquement à des sanctions et
de nouveaux règlements qui ont été mis
en place depuis que les états unis
s'intéressent au sort des 8 bourg
ça pourrait donc conduire la chine a
accéléré ses échanges avec l'europe
puisque toutes les portes se ferment
côté américain et bien
on peut penser que côté europe avec la
grèce l'italie la chine à quelques
entrées intéressantes mais même la
catalogne aussi les chinois sont très
présents donc je pense que aussi bien
l'europe et que la chine ont tout à fait
intérêt effectivement à trouver des
moyens de contournement du droit
américain du jcp aux as merci philippe
béchade d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de la bourse au quotidien et
membres d econoclaste